[Music]
in the deserts of the American Southwest
spadefoot toad tadpoles hatch in tiny
Oasis until they develop into toadlets
they can't survive outside of water but
these ponds are transient and quickly
evaporate the tadpoles are in a race
against the clock to grow up before
their nurseries disappear so nearly
overnight some of the brood explode in
size they use their jack-o'-lantern
teeth and huge jaw muscles to devour
their smaller pond mates nourished by
this extra fuel they develop quicker
leaving the pond before it can dry out
the spadefoot toad is far from the only
animal to eat members of its own species
as a normal part of its lifecycle all of
these animals do if that surprises you
you're in good company until recently
scientists thought cannibalism was a
rare response to starvation or other
extreme stress well-known cannibals like
the praying mantis and black widow
spider were considered bizarre
exceptions but now we know they more or
less represent the rule while it may
seem counterproductive for members of
the same species to eat each other
cannibalism can promote the survival of
the species as a whole by reducing
competition calling the weak and
bolstering the strong some species like
the spadefoot toad cannibalize in
response to environmental pressures
their situation is precarious but
cannibalism for them isn't a last-ditch
attempt to avoid starvation rather it's
a way to more quickly outgrow a stage
where they're especially vulnerable to
predation or dangerous environmental
conditions other species including many
fish indiscriminately cannibalize each
other during foraging behavior fish
produce large numbers of tiny young and
adults exhibit about as much individual
recognition of their offspring as humans
do for a handful of raisins fish eggs
larvae and juveniles are easily
available nutrient-rich meals and with
thousands of eggs in a clutch plenty are
still available to hatch after the
adults have
baby fish aren't just at risk of being
cannibalized by adults siblings eat each
other - sand tiger shark eggs develop
and hatch inside their mothers OVA ducts
at different times when the hatchlings
run out of yolk from their own eggs
they eat the other eggs and hatchlings
until one baby shark from each oviduct
remains when they emerge the young
sharks are well nourished experienced
predators who stand a better chance of
surviving even when they aren't consumed
for nutrition young animals are
especially vulnerable to cannibalism
hamsters rats and other rodents mothers
will eat some of their young if they're
sick dead or simply too numerous to feed
in other mammals including bears and
lions males will kill offspring sired by
another that's because childless females
become receptive to mating more quickly
than if they were caring for a cub
rather than waste nutritious meat the
male's then eat the dead Cubs meanwhile
cannibalism is less common in birds than
in other groups but certain species will
eat diseased or dead hatchlings as a way
of disposing of the bodies before they
can attract maggots when adults eat each
other males are cannibalized more often
than females usually during mating and
generally because they're smaller male
Australian Redback spiders mate with
much larger females rather than
scrambling away after mating the tiny
male does a somersault bringing his
abdomen into contact with his mates
mouth parts the female showers him with
enzyme rich gut juice and consumes his
abdomen males not killed in the initial
mating crawled back into the fray often
half
to mate again after which they're
dispatched to the spider pantry so not
only does the male provide the female
with his sperm but he also provides her
with a nutritious meal to better ensure
that she'll survive to pass on his genes
all in all it's clear that cannibalism
is as much a part of life in the animal
kingdom as other better recognized
behaviors as we sink our teeth into the
evidence of cannibalism in nature we
might ask ourselves what else have we
missed by applying human standards to
the natural world interested in learning
more we highly recommend you check out
cannibalism a perfectly natural history
by the author of this lesson
[Music]